it has always been a little confusing to
select the perfect programming language
we have carried out rigorous surveys and
come up with a list of the top five
programming languages for 2022. at
number five we have php
being rather old php maintains its might
in web development believe it or not but
a total of 21 percent of developers
worldwide are actively using php
php is a general purpose scripting
language used for web development it is
one of the first server site scripting
languages to get embedded into an html
code
companies still use php in their web
application development cars 24 facebook
wikipedia are a few examples
the average salary of a php developer is
80 000 usc and in india an average php
developer earns around 6 to 8 lakhs per
annum at number 4 we have sql
the humble sql has been in the it
industry for a while and it's believed
to be around for a few more years
sql is a structured query language that
is built to interact with data storage
units like relational databases and
advanced versions of sql are capable of
interaction with the cloud
sql is still in great demand and
companies like accenture rapido dell
cognizant and ntt data are actively
hiring database sql developers and
architects
the average salary of an sql developer
is 80 000 us dollars per annum and in
india sql developers earn 10 likes per
annum on an average
at number three we have java
java undoubtedly has a broad spectrum of
applications and a huge developer
community worldwide
the famous repository hosting service
the github is the home for three lakh
thirty thousand five fifty repositories
and serves as an open source for over 15
million active java developers round the
clock
java is the most dominating object
oriented programming language currently
in use in the iit industry
java is used for android development
software development desktop and mobile
application development big data and
much more major leading tech giants like
uber airbnb instagram paytm and google
use java the average salary of java
developers in the united states is about
100 000 usd per annum and in india a
java developer can earn about 12 lakhs
per annum
at number 2 we have python
python the constant adversary of java
the next leading programming language
with cutting edge features and nearly an
unlimited range of applications python
stands as a commendable programming
language python is a general purpose
object oriented and also a scripting
programming language
it is a powerful ruler of data analytics
and also web development
intel ibm pixar spotify razer pay and
many leading software companies are in
use of python the average salary of a
python developer is 125 000 usc and in
india the average salary of a python
developer is around 10 to 12 lakhs per
annum
at number one we have javascript
javascript the internet's language often
abbreviated as js stands as the segment
leader dominating the world of software
development
nearly 65 percent of the developers
community is dependent on javascript
javascript is a general purpose
scripting language extensively used for
web application development javascript
is capable to handle both front end and
back end and deliver interactive web
pages
major tech giants like paypal netflix
picbasket and google use javascript
the average salary of a javascript
developer is one ten thousand us dollars
and eight to ten lakhs per annum in
india and with that we have come to an
end of this session of top five
programming languages for 2022 if you
have any queries or feel we missed out
on anything important please feel free
to let us know in the comment section
below a gentle reminder to leave us your
likes and also your subscription to the
channel will be appreciated thank you
for watching till next time stay safe
and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here